bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 78 weekend
l'émission consacrée à vos loisirs et
vos idées de sortiese nous vous
parlerons bien sûr des journées du
patrimoine de golf également mais tout
d'abord place à l'un des événements phar
du weekend la Journée nationale du
cheval
alors la Journée nationale du cheval je
le disais c'est ce weekend dimanche 21
septembre pour cette 25e édition les
centres équestres ouvrent leurs portes
dans toute la France y compris dans les
ivelines pour en parler sur notre
plateau Cyril Turmel bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes le directeur du club
ipic de Versailles et à l'occasion de
cette fête vous ouvrez donc les portes
au grand public dimanche alors qu'z-vous
proposer durant cette journée voilà donc
d' bonjour effectivement on est placé
Porsche fontaine à Versailles donc le
but de cette journée nationale c'est que
tous les centres équestres en France
puissent ouvrir leurs portes présenter
toutes les activités et permettre aux
gens bah de venir essayer alors que ce
soit les enfants les adultes tout le
monde doit pouvoir participer monter à
cheval donc nous on ouvre à partir de
14h pour tout le public ils vont pouvoir
venir à partir de 10h pour assister à
une compétition de s d'obstacle mais ils
pourront pas participer vont être
spectateurs donc il y aura le matin une
compétition de obstacle poney
l'après-midi ça va vers 13h 14h on va
lancer la compétition chevaux donc avec
des adolescents et quelques adultes et
parallèlement bah on va permettre aux
gens de mettre les enfants à partir de 3
ans sur les poney sur des baptêms
entièrement gratuits bien sûr et puis de
d'initier les adultes à cheval donc on
va leur laisser quelques chevaux les
initier leur montrer bah que c'est
possible aussi pour un public plus âgé
de commencer le cheval sans sans
craintre également quelques
démonstrations oui bien sûr pour montrer
bah toutes les activités qu'on propose
nous au club et au niveau national aussi
et avoir des démonstrations de dressage
avec des RLM donc c'est des reprises
libres en musique donc c'est des figures
imposées avec de la musique donc c'est
assez sympa à voir il y aura bah du
sobstac qu'ils ont déjà vu sur le CSO
mais on fera encore des démonstrations
du du ponyam et du ponyames ouais tout à
fait alors ça ça cible bah les enfants
donc c'est des équipes en général entre
4 et 6 qui s'affrontent sur des jeux
donc c'est très pédag très pédagogue
comme comme environnement ça permet aux
jeunes d'apprendre à faire du poney en
oubliant la peur en fait de l'animal
parce qu'ils sont pris dans les jeux et
il y a plein de jeux différents et ça
met une ambiance d'équipe vous proposez
également du horse ball qu'est-ce que
c'est voà le hor ball bah c'est tout le
monde connaît le foot bien sûr donc nous
c'est le un jeu de balle mais à poney ou
à cheval donc ça s'envoie à la main et
c'est un peu plus comme du basket pour
aller marquer les paniers c'est des
animations gratuites donc tout est
gratuit weend ouais dimanche vous pouvez
venir de 10h à 18h tout est entièrement
gratuit on est là pour vous montrer ce
qu'on sait faire et ce qu'on peut vous
proposer tout au long de l'année mais
aussi pour que vous puissiez essayer bah
de monter à poney un cheval dans une
ambiance assez sympathique et puis on va
vous faire découvrir sur toute la
structure les écuries le manège la
carrière VO toute la visite nous on est
sur 2 hectares donc on a beaucoup de
place on est en bord de forêt donc il y
a beaucoup de chose à voir alors c'est
la 25e édition de cette journée
nationale du cheval est-ce qu'elle est
encore nécessaire enfin pourquoi cette
journée en fait finalement bah elle est
nécessaire parce que il y a encore
beaucoup de gens qui n'osent pas
franchir le le cap on se dit souvent
l'équitation c'est un sport un petit peu
réservé à une clientelle riche et cetera
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que
l'excitation c'est énormément
démocratisée en France c'est un pays en
Europe où l'équitation est le moins cher
à pratiquer donc ça c'est important de
le savoir et du coup il y a encore des
gens qui sont un petit peu réticents qui
ent pas franchir le capâ de passer la
barrière alors que on peut venir
régulièrement se promener avec les
enfants dans le centreest ça pose pas de
problème mais il y a encore des gens qui
hésitent à venir donc de faire cette
promo de dire c'est une journée
nationale bah les gens franchissent le
pas et là on est là pour les accueillir
pour leur montrer vraiment notre travail
notre passion leur faire découvrir notre
passion et justement le pouvoir leur
montrer que ils peuvent eux aussi mettre
en gros le pied à l'étrier si onut faire
un petit peu d'humour sur cette journée
nationale alors on va quand même le le
préciser la une part beaucoup plus
importante de de femmes dans dans ce
sport 83 % de cavalières et 7 % de
cavaliers qu'est-ce qui explique ça à
votre avis bah c'est vrai que ça se
renforce de plus en plus on a de
femmes bon ce qui faut savoir si vous
voulez c'est que beaucoup de jeunes
veulent faire de l'équitation donc nous
on les prend à partir de 3 ans aux
écuries entre 3 5 ans c'est des petits
cours baby Shetland c'est un premier
contact un première approche une
première approche là on retrouve
énormément de de filles qui veulent
faire ce sport peut-être pour le contact
de l'animal et du coup après bah on
garde
cette clientèle là ces adhérents et du
coup on a très peu
de de gantes masculines il y a il y a
c'est c'est le premier sport féminin en
France carrément voilà il y a également
5000 centres et Cestres en France on est
quand même bien servi au niveau de on
est bien servi mais c'est une grosse
fédération c'est la trè Fédération
française on a 700000 licenciés un peu
plus de 700000 licenciés on est en Haus
chaque année donc c'est un sport qui se
développe donc ça c'est très bien mais
effectivement qui est très féminin très
féminin il y a également des on en parle
souvent des atouts santé et moral à la
pratique du cheval ouais bah oui bon
santé c'est un peu comme tous les sports
dire vous forcément vous musclez bon il
y a tout un travail qui se fait qui se
développe sur la respiration et cetera
après psychique c'est aussi le fait
d'être avec le le contact de l'animal il
y a beaucoup d'enfants bah finalement
c'est un peu leur confident et puis il y
a ce contact ce respect si vous
respectez pas l'animal il va vous faire
savoir donc euh ça remet les
barrières voilà donc il y a beaucoup
d'atouts euh comme ça ce soit
psychologique physique qui développe un
acquis la confiance en soi aussi parce
qu'une fois qu'on arrive à être sur le
poney sur le cheval à diriger à
s'arrêter à le faire sauter à quelque
part on prend un petit peu de confiance
c'est une activité sympa aussi qu'on
peut faire partout au bord de l'eau en
on peut faire partout voilà et qui est
très varié parce que vous avez
l'quisation classique pour apprendre
comme nous on pratique dans les manèges
dans les carrières chà sympa parce que
vous êtes aussi à l'extérieur vous
pouvez aller vous balader puis après
vous allez vraiment la randonner
effectivement sur la plage ou ou autre
mais et on on peut débuter à très très
tôt donc aujourd'hui il des cours de
baby poney c'est ça vous en parlez tout
à l'heure ouais 3 ans on les prend à
partir de 3 ans tout à fait ouais donc
c'est surtout pour le contact avec
l'animal hein sur 1 heure de cours pour
les 3 ans vous allez monter 20 25
minutes après il y a à savoir s'en
occuper le brosser c'est et cetera donc
ça une première approche pour pas qu'ils
aient peur ensuite donc on les met
progressivement sur les poneys et après
à partir 5 ans 6 ans B ils monent
beaucoup plus et après ils sont tout de
suite à l'aise très bien mais maintenant
on peut aussi débuter à 30 40 ans il pas
il y a pas d'âge pas d'â pour comcer
alors vous en savez un petit peu plus
maintenant on espère vous avoir donné
envie d'aller à la découverte de cette
discipline dimanche donc à versaill au
club ipic c'est donc à partir de 14h au
programme on vous l'a dit des visites
des baptêmes à ponis des initiations au
cheval ainsi que des démonstrations
alors à 50 ans neline et ses alentours
notez également que les clubs écastres
et épiques de trappe de rambouillé du
chaîné de Gazeran de bois d'arc ou
encore de chevreuses participe également
à cette journée mercici vous Cyril merci
d'être venu sur notre plateau on passe
maintenant à l'autre actualité du
weekend les journées du
patrimoine je le disais dans les titres
des samedis les journées du patrimoine
vont rythmer votre weekend et pour cette
31e édition c'est le thème de la nature
qui est mis en avant parmi les
animations autour de l'étang de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline la compagnie
Talia théâtre propose un spectacle
appelé c'est dans l'eau c'est une
création qui sera présentée samedi 20
septembre dans l'après-midi Catherine
julato et Patrick Jacques de dixmun on
rencontré les comédiens et la metteur en
scène en répétition à La
Verrière cette année les Journées du
patrimoine sont dédié à la nature et la
culture Talia théâtre a donc imaginé un
spectacle autour de l'eau un spectacle
présenté par des comédiens des Musici un
circassien la troupe de la scarabande
ils seront en représentation à la base
de loisir de 50 ans nous créons à partir
d'imag que j'ai préparé et puis après on
les expérimente et on essaie de voir si
ça tient la
route alors on va décliner l'eau l'eau
des loisirs l'eau
historique l'eau de la
création l'eau qui engloutit tout et
l'eau qui reprend son terrain et qui
peut-être nous fait disparaître si on
fait pas attention il y a une petite
virgule au parapluies de cherbour ici
nous sommes plutôt dans les parapluis de
de la verrière ou de trappe il y a des
petites virgules comme ça il y aura
Marie Antoinette aussi par exemple
puisque elle elle a fait pas mal de
choses avec l'eau elle a vraiment voulu
la maîtriser et l'utiliser à fond euh
donc il y a des petites virgules des
petites images comme ça et et nous avons
un machinoir c'est le musée de la ville
qui a proposé la base de loisir et nous
avons fait visite ensemble pour voir
dans quel endroit nous pourrions faire
ce spectacle on a choisi un endroit un
petit peu un petit peu entouré on va
dire ça comme ça il y aura aussi une
petite expo de photos et je pense que ça
va être beau convivial un peu drôle et
puis on espère qu'il pleuvera
pas et à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine toujours le château de
Versailles présente ce weekend les
espaces et collections des galeries
historiques une visite exceptionnelle à
découvrir également Aurélia debussi et
William
l cette année encore les Journées du
Patrimoine sont l'occasion d'ouvrir de
nouvelles portes du château de
Versailles ce weekend deux étages de
l'aile du Nord dévoileront les espaces
et collections des galeries du château
un musée historique créé par
LouisPhilippe en 1830 dédié à toutes les
gloires de la France alors là vous allez
découvrir au premier
étage peinture surtout espèce de grande
présentation du règne de Louis XIV
depuis son enfance jusqu'à sa mort donc
la grande figure de Versailles et ici au
second étage nous avons des salles
consacrées en fait à la pratiquement au
19e siècle après Napoléon c'est-à-dire
depuis le retour des Bourbons sur le
trône en 1814-1815 avec les deux
restaurations et jusqu'à la Première
Guerre mondiale donc un siècle
d'histoire de France une partie de
l'histoire de France évoquée par des
tableaux officiels et portraits
commandés par les différents régimes qui
se sont succédés ou bien offerts par par
des familles désirant s'inscrire dans
l'histoire de France les journées du
patrimoine au château de Versailles sont
donc l'occasion de voyager à travers ces
collections méconnu du grand public la
plupart des visiteurs de Versailles
ignorent totalement en fait qu'il y a ce
musée historique qui est en quelque
sorte caché derrière la la résidence
royale c'est comme la partie immergée en
fait d'un iceberg puisque les
collections historiques de Versailles
sont un ensemble absolument énorme que
Louis-Philippe avait installé dans tout
le château et petit à petit la résidence
royale a reconquis certains espaces les
appartements historiques mais il y a
toujours de très nombreuses salles
historiques que nous avons donc
l'occasion de montrer pour les Journées
du Patrimoine en attendant de pouvoir
les montrer plus plus souvent plus
facilement plus normalement en fait au
public d'ici on espère quelques années
une visite inédite à découvrir
gratuitement samedi et dimanche de 9h à
17h un programme ex extrêmement varié
vous attends donc ce weekend pour ces
journée du patrimoine alors voici encore
quelques idées et à Versailles toujours
il vous sera possible de vis visiter la
préfecture et le Conseil général deux
entités dans le même bâtiment c'est le
di le samedi 20 et le dimanche 21
septembre direction La Verrière
maintenant c'est une visite assez
exceptionnelle que vous nous que nous
vous vous proposons au château de La
Verrière un lieu rarement ouvert au
public où vous aurez l'occasion de
déambuler de la petite chapelle aux
salalles de réception Hornet de
boiseries anciennes pensez à réserver au
musée de la ville on reste dans
l'agglomération avec le fort de
saint-cire un fort militaire construit à
montinil tenu après la guerre de
1870 une visite qui plaît toujours c'est
le samedi et le dimanche allez on passe
du côté de manilamo un circuit pédestre
et en bus vous propose de découvrir les
fermes historiques il y en a quatre
Gomberville Buloyer lesganges de Port
Royal et champ Garnier à Saint-Lambert
des bois c'est le samedi 2 20 septembre
de 13h30 à 18h30 rendez-vous devant la
Maison de l'Environnement alors ce là
bien sûr qu'un aperçu de ce qui vous est
proposé pour ces journées du patrimoine
pour le programme complet n'hésitez pas
à visionner notre dernière émission
culturelle kiosque sur notre site
internet TVfil 78.com l'émission du
mercredi 17 septembre à revoir dans la
rubrique
replay je le disais dans les titres
également on parle de golf à présent
avec notre invité bonjour bonjour vous
êtes annelise kyot directrice des sports
à la communauté d'agglomération de 50
ans en liveline et alors ce vendredi 19
septembre c'est la 3e édition de la Nuit
du golf l'occasion de jouer en nocturne
au Golf National de guillancour alors
qu'est-ce que c'est concrètement
qu'est-ce que vous proposez alors
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est la possibilité
de découvrir le golf dans toutes ces
pratiques pour les novic également pour
ceux qui ont déjà l'habitude de jouer de
jouer dans un contexte un petit peu
original c'est-à-dire de nuit donc c'est
ouvert à tous c'est gratuit à partir de
18h ce soir on propose donc pour ceux
qui ont l'habitude de jouer à partir de
20h un parcours de nuit donc tout à fait
exceptionnel avec des balles lumineuses
un parcours qui est également éclairé
c'est assez c'est assez amusant et pour
les personnes qui n'ont pas l'habitude
de jouer même pour les enfants on a des
animations pour les jeunes à partir de 6
ans et vous pouvez découvrir la pratique
du golf au travers de diverses
animations au travers de concours
également tout ça à partir de 18h ces
concours justement j'ai vu qu'il y en
avait plusieurs qui étaient proposé
c'est c'est quoi c'est le concours alors
vous avez des concours de Drive des
concours de putting des sorties de bon
ça a lieu toutes les heures donc à
partir de 19h l'idée c'est de montrer sa
dextérité qu'on soit novice ou ou
pratiquant soit on est vraiment très bon
et on y arrive avec un coup de chance ça
peut être intéressant aussi c'est la 3è
édition cette année quelle est
l'objectif principal de cette journée
alors l'objectif principal c'est de
faire découvrir le golf comme je le
disais à tous les ctinois qu'ils aient
l'habitude ou pas de jouer les deux
premières éditions étaient surtout à
destination des licenciés du territoire
pour leur faire découvrir le golf
national puisque c'est là qu'a a lieu la
rider Cup en 2018 donc les invités à
venir découvrir là encore la pratique
mais de manière un petit peu originale
et à partir de cette année on a fait le
choix d'ouvrir au grand public l'idée
pour que ce soit amusant c'est que un
golfeur vienne avec un non golfeur pour
lui faire découvrir aussi la pratique et
venir ensemble voilà à l'image justement
de l'équitation dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est un sport qui a un peu
l'image élitiste avant est-ce que le
golf c'est toujours le cas est-ce que
justement il y a besoin encore de
d'événements comme ça alors
effectivement on ressent effectivement
le besoin la Fédération Française de
Golf également on s'en est rendu compte
dès 2011 au moment de l'attribution de
la rider Cup il y a toujours beaucoup de
préjugés autour de la pratique et l'idée
justement en vue de la rider Cup en
France c'est démocratiser la discipline
c'est de montrer également que ça n'est
pas si cliché que ça tout le monde peut
pratiquer ou presque il est vrai que
c'est un sport qui peut être un petit
peu onéreux mais l'agglomération a
néanmoins mis en place plusieurs actions
plusieurs projets pour permettre aux CIN
contintinois quel que soit leur profil
de découvrir la discipline la rider Cup
on va présenter un petit peu ce que
c'est donc c'est vraiment une
compétition très très médiatisée la plus
une des plus médiatisées au monde pour
pour le golf en tout cas si vous pouvez
nous présenter un petit peu ce que c'est
pour les pour les novic tout à fait
alors la rider Cup elle a lieu tous les
2 ans et alternativement tous les 4 ans
en France et aux États-Unis elle a lieu
là d'ailleurs la semaine prochaine en
Écosse donc j'invite tous ceux que ça
pourra intéresser à à regarder
d'ailleurs ils pourront venir au golf
national pour pour regarder la rider Cup
donc c'est intéressant donc ça oppose
une équipe comme je le disais des
États-Unis à une équipe européenne ce
sont les les meilleurs joueurs pardon
européens qui s'opposent aux meilleurs
joueurs américains donc le sport c'est
aussi une pratique d'équipe
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
euh et voilà donc ça dure à peu près une
semaine il y a 3 jours d'entraînement et
les trois jours réels de compétition qui
sont le vendredi le samedi et le
dimanche et c'est effectivement l'un des
événements les plus médiatisés au monde
dans les trois quatre premiers à peu
près euh l'édition 2010 avait donc
attiré titre indicatif 700 millions de
téléspectateurs quand même et 400000
spectateurs par jour là-bas au pays de
Gal à l'époque en 2010 euh 400000 je
pense que c'est sur la totalité de de la
semaine en général il y a à peu près
50000 spectateurs par jour par jour
c'est déjà pas mal oui c'est déjà
beaucoup et donc c'est c'est un grand
événement pour alors c'est un grand
c'est un grand événement effectivement
pour pour 50 ans en Evelin donc en 2018
d'ici là comme je le disais
l'agglomération met en place plusieurs
actions auprès des scolaires auprès de
jeunes en difficulté scolair et auprès
du grand public pour faire découvrir la
discipline et à côté de ça
l'agglomération travaille également avec
la Fédération Française de Golf la
préfecture le Conseil général les
communes alentours pour permettre
d'accueillir dans de très bonnes
conditions les 50 à 70000 spectateurs
qui viendrai chaque jour à 50 ans en
yeline dans 4 ans rapidement du coup
pour 50 ans en Yveline qu'est-ce que
vous proposez pour sensibiliser
justement les jeunes et les moins jeunes
au golf alors l'action donc qui a lieu
ce soir est une action destinée au grand
public nous avons une autre action qui a
lieu au mois de juin euh au centre
commercial de saquanttin en Yveline donc
destiné au grand public là aussi on fait
découvrir dans un milieu urbain c'est un
petit peu original euh nous avons
également des actions en faveur des
scolaires notamment des écoles primaires
depuis 2 ans euh auprès des classes de
CMA et et CM2 principalement de toute
l'agglomération et nous avons également
des projets avec des jeunes en
difficulté comme je le disais
l'opération crocogolf qui a été initiée
en 2008 par la Fédération Française de
Golf 550 an Yveline était pilote euh un
projet également avec l'école de la 2e
de la deuxème chance pardon et le club
face pour essayer de raccrocher ces
jeunes un petit peu en difficulté soit
Scola soit professionnell un certain
nombre de valeurs et euh essayer de leur
faire poursuivre un peu plus les études
en tout cas les raccrocher à un métier
beaucoup de choses tout ça alors si
c'est une discipline qui vous attire en
tout cas l'occasion est toute trouvée
pour la tester gratuitement à l'occasion
de la 3e nuit du golf je le répète c'est
ce vendredi 19 septembre à partir de 18h
au Golf National de guilloncour merci an
d'être venue sur notre plateau alors en
loisir toujours une autre idée de sortie
pour vous ce weekend à l'occasion de la
2e édition de ver les Yvelines une
balade guidée à vélo vous est proposé
pour découvrir la forêt de Port Royal
une traversée organisée avec
l'association velos Sky et l'office de
tourisme où pique-nique et atelier
ludique vous attendent rendez-vous à la
gare de C an en Éveline pour le
départ on continue cette édition avec du
sport le Grand Prix des Yvelines de
stock car s'est déroulé à garencière il
y a quelques jours une pratique pour le
moins originale ou tonneau et
carambolage font le bonheur des
spectateurs Anthony R et Willam William
l était sur place ces anciennes R5 ou
205 sont pimpantes et rutilantes mais
pas encore pour très longtemps car ces
26 pilotes déjantés vont s'affronter sur
une piste ovale de 200 m anneau qui en
temps normal pourrait accueillir tro ou
qure V
ça défoule un peu ça permet de faire ce
qu'on veut pas faire sur la route quoi
voilà tout
simplement voilà le weekend c'est le
défou la semaine on est sage pouvoir
tourner un petit peu en PIR pousser les
autre quoi c'est c'est voilà c'est
vraiment tout donc ça un petit peu
pilotage entre guillemets et un peu de
finesse en évitant les autres et en pon
moment pour lesliminer une fois le top
départ les pilotes doivent effuer 20
tours ridement possible mais attention
au tonneau et au
carambolage un petit jeu de massacre qui
passionne le millier de personnes amass
derrière les barrières de sécurité
l'ambiance fait d'avoir toutes les
voitures qui se fon d c'est toujours
sympa le côté spectaculaire on voit pas
ça tous les jours on aimerait bien être
à la place des personnes qui font ça oré
des États-Unis le stock car est une
discipline où les voitures sont
spécialement préparées pour jouer du
pare-choc et enchaîner les tonneaux avec
des habitacle totalement réaménagé car
ici tous les coups sont permis ou
presque il y a des règlements des
règlements c'est-à-dire que par exemple
chaque pilote ne peut pas bousculer son
collègue sur le côté il faut que ça soit
obligatoirement à l'arrière du véhicule
si les pilotes ne craignent rien pour
certaines carrosseries il va falloir
repasser au garage
avant la prochaine
course en sport toujours et il y a de
quoi faire ce weekend à l'occasion de la
5e édition de santé vous sport l'île de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin en Yveline vous
propose de découvrir gratuitement des
activités nombreuses et variées parmi
elles une marche nordique vous est
proposée samedi 20 et dimanche 21
septembre dès 15h pour les amateurs de
pétanque le 4e open se déroule ce samedi
20 septembre à voisin le Bretonneux
pensez à vous inscrire auprès du Centre
Alfred de Viny rendez-vous dès 9h30 au
lac de la Sourderie et enfin direction
trapou se déroule le 17e rally de
l'Office Municipal des Sports un rally
gratuit et ouvert à tous les résultats
seront donnés à partir de 18h30 à la
salle Jean-Baptiste Clément
est du cinéma à présent avec les sortie
ciné de la semaine et les avis des
spectateurs au micro de William H c'est
super c'est un film c'est un petit bijou
et puis l'envin bon moi c'est un
acteur immense à voir à tout prix parce
que vraiment c'est un bon moment
excellent comme film sans prétention
très simple c'est très très très drôle
très fin enfin c'est du jean becécer
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup aimé Gérard
Lambin bah comme d'habitude puis tous
ces acteurs qui passent ces dialogues
c'est très très agréable c'est charmant
c'était pas
mal PIR est très très bien dedans euh
quelques longueurs quand même et des
plans un peu incompréhensibles des fois
c'est très bien joué très bien tourné de
bons acteurs mais euh au niveau de de
l'histoire et donc j'étais un petit peu
déçu super film très très bien comme
tous les les films adaptés des romans de
John mcaré c'est parfois un peu
compliqué mais celui-ci était très très
très bien vraiment cétait oui c'était
très bien ouais c'était intéressant
ouais il y avait de l'action sans sans
avir de l'action un film américain plein
de bon sentiments rien de
plus place maintenant au coup de cœur de
la semaine celui d'un professionnel du
7e avec Bertrand Pignier des yeux d'Elsa
à senscir l'école le coup de cœur de la
semaine au cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa sinsir
l'école c'est le compte de la princesse
Kaguya le dernier né de la des studios
gibleli après le vent se lève dernier
film annoncé de Ayao Miyazaki voici le
dernier film annoncé de Isao takaata son
comparse de toujours c'est donc
l'histoire d'une princesse qui nait dans
un bambou c'est un compte qui date du 9e
siècle au Japon que tous les Japonais
connaissent que nous connaissons moins
mais que Isa otakaata reprend pour en
faire une sorte de compte d'odde à la
nature au lien entre l'homme et la
nature c'est un film qui est accessible
dès très petit dès 6 7 ans
et c'est un film avec un univers
graphique absolument foisonnant avec une
musique absolument bouleversante et une
histoire qui plaira à tout le monde des
plus petits au plus
âgés
je vous invite à venir le voir au cinéma
Les Yeux d'Elsa donc dès cette semaine
et puis encore pour une semaine puisque
c'est un film qu'on a décider de
soutenir et de garder un peu
longtemps c'est la fin de cette édition
du 78 weekend merci de nous avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous lundi des 18h avec
l'actualité sur TVfil 78 d'ici là je
vous souhaite un excellent
weekend